hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video ich bin gerade wach
geworden und habe heute einen kleinen
block vor
und so hat ist ja wahrscheinlich schon
am titel gelesen es geht heute um 24
stunden ohne elektronik ich hab mir
gedacht früher hat man es ja auch
geschafft vor 200 jahren wieso dann mich
heute ist irgendwie eine interessante
idee finde ich das heißt handy werks
macbook weg fernseher weg stolberg
autowerk hoch und weg und so weiter also
irgendwie alles was man sonst so brauch
ich bin mal gespannt wie der heutige tag
aussehen wird die kamera ist natürlich
das einzige elektronische was ich dabei
habe so weit sind
ich wollte jetzt eigentlich die schon
sehen und durchfahrt mich jetzt gerade
was genau ist an einer dusche
elektronisch klar wenn das wasser
erhitzt wird hat das bestimmt irgendwas
mit elektronik zu tun dann habe ich
irgendwie gar nicht gedacht allerdings
würde ich sagen wenn ich kalt duschen
ist die elektronik praktisch
ausgeschaltet weil das ist ja ganz
normales wassers aus dem boden kommt
nach keine ahnung nicht durch jetzt
einfach dann geht's los
bis gleich ich habe sie wollten das so
schlimm und hier live
aber das gute ist jetzt ist der match
aber ich habe fertig bedroht
meine haare film ist mir aber
aufgefallen kann ich ja auch nicht
deswegen der gute tropfen eigentlich zu
bestellen sind ja noch nicht so lange
übrigens habe ich jetzt letztes mal den
gedanken mir im sommer an dreadlocks
macht aber nicht mal richtige weil ich
will das jetzt schon mal die kinder
immer irgend meinung in die kommentare
schreiben
aber ich glaube nicht so bewandert sind
dumme gedanken
ansonsten steht heute eigentlich nicht
so viel an ich muss gleich zur post ein
paket abholen so hatte ich sitze jetzt
in meinem schreibtisch und jetzt habe
ich noch ein bisschen zeit euch zu
erklären was ich heute genau machen
werden oder was ich vorher also wie
schon gesagt geht es heute darum 24
stunden also bis morgen früh ohne strom
aus zu kommen ohne elektronik einfach
weil ich mir gedacht habe
seit planung sechs sieben acht jahren
habe ich glaube ich keinen tag mehr
verbracht ohne einmal aus hinten zu
schauen ohne mich mal vor dem computer
zu setzen und durch wald vor dem
fernseher zu setzen und so weiter das
sind ja alles dinge die sind völlig
normal geworden und wie es dann ist wenn
man die dinge plötzlich nicht mehr hat
das werde ich dann ja heute erfahren
also wir haben hier ein macbook wir
haben ja mein handy der fernseher mein
auto usw
ich würde sagen das licht mache ich
nicht mal an hier brauche ich auch gar
nicht gut heute abend jetzt ein bisschen
dunkeln es ist doch auch einfach mal
geil nicht aufs handy zu schauen nicht
diesen druck zu haben leuten
schnellstmöglich antworten zu müssen
deswegen habe ich das jetzt alles mal
irgendwohin so leid ich habe mich jetzt
hier nach draußen gesetzt weil
das ist gutes wetter irgendwie gestern
war es noch kalt und heute plötzlich
zusammen und es tut mir leid dass die
straße so laut ist auf jeden fall habe
ich gleich um 12 uhr
und ich muss gleich erst kurz zur post
und dann gehen wir in die stadt oder ich
also wir sehen uns gleich erst jetzt
erstmal ein toastbrot wie man sehen kann
um getoastet und ein café also leute bis
gleich
[Applaus]
trink mal was sie so leute ich weiß
gerade weil der post und habe dieses
pakete abgeholt und ich wüsste nicht was
es sonst sein sollte außer ein handy was
ich letztens noch bayerisch bestellt
habe ich habe da ja eigentlich schon als
auflösungs video zu gemacht wenn er das
noch nicht gesehen hat sie ja auf jeden
fall an und ich musste das handy
eigentlich zoll abholen die haben wir
dann aber geschrieben dass das wohl das
falsche war es war ja auch nicht das was
auf dem foto weise was ich eigentlich
bestellt
und jetzt habe ich zwei handys obwohl
ich nur eines bestellt habe und ob ich
das andere wieder abgeben soll oder
nicht
ich habe keine ahnung wo ich gucke jetzt
mal rein und dann sehen was ja heute
schon noch ein
ihr könnt euch das mal an also made in
china solar das andere wirklich nicht
aus also das ist wirklich das was ich
bestellt habe glaube ich hier haben wir
das handy für 31 euro
ich würde gerne machen mache ich weiter
aber nicht weil wir einen tag ohne
elektronik verbringen
aber wenn du die ganze story dazu gold
und ich das vielleicht auch mal
ausprobieren soll
und es wird auch von los und holte man
sehen gibt einfach mal nach oben oder
schritte die kommentare und wir gehen
jetzt vielleicht in die stadt
wobei das scheint sie kommen nicht in
die stadt muss man irgendwas überlegen
oder wer gut zu fuß sind so einem ein
kilometer aber auch nachbar also leute
bis gleich so leute wir gehen jetzt so
kam es nach dieser seite
es ist auf jeden fall mehr und da unten
schöne nackte menschen mitten in köln
die menschen da unten schön einfach
nackt
ich darf aber leider nirgendwo mit euch
mitfahren war ich mache 24 stunden ohne
elektronik und das ist ja alles
elektronik
leute uns aufgefallen aber auch noch
ganz dringend ein geldautomat aber ich
darf man kein geld benutzen also den
automaten nicht benutzen
so wären
gib mir geld fünf euro das entscheidet
jeder hat gesehen was die leute ich habe
da wirklich nur drei euro fünfzig es
reicht in essen aus der chinesen
vielleicht mal sehen bis gleich
[Musik]
was geht so leute wie auf der kirmes
wir wollten auch ins riesenrad gehen
also die beiden haben wir aber nicht
gemacht das hat sieben euro gekostet und
jetzt machen wir das so leute kleines
update das ding ist ohne handy also ich
hab wirklich kein handy dabei ich habe
ein stück sind dabei und mein
portemonnaie greifen automatisch so zur
tasche aber da ist einfach nichts drin
und was auch extrem aufhält man kann nie
genau sagen wie spät es ist also ich
sage nicht nur ich habe immer nur mein
handy dabei und ja das ist halt das
problem aber sonst ist alles cool ich
fühle mich voll preise sodass wir wollen
jetzt irgendwo essen gehen wir müssen
aber einen tisch bestellen
ich habe aber kein handy dabei das heißt
die beiden müssen das übernehmen
so leute es ist jetzt total dumm wenn
ich das nicht auslassen würde weil dann
will ich nicht sehen also als ich hatte
zwar eigentlich war 24 stunden komplett
oder elektronen zu machen und das wäre
für das video echt blöd und die qualität
wird darunter leiden dass wenn ich
irgendwann auch scheiße handys weg
macbook ist weg fernsehen ist weg
internet ist weg so das ist ja diese
social media was ich jeden tag benutzt
und ich glaube das sollte reichen so
schon besser auf jeden fall machen wir
noch kurz bei freund dann haben wir alle
zusammen was essen und wir haben jetzt
schon ungefähr neu oder halb zehn war
wir haben euch schon 10 uhr nur ich hab
irgendwie schon wieder hunger ich wollte
mir auf jeden fall noch was zu essen
machen das ding ist ich habe keine
ahnung was eigentlich wollte ich mir
eine ofenkartoffel machen weil ich habe
echt gerne ofenkartoffeln es allerdings
ist mir noch nie aufgefallen dafür
brauchst den ofen
da gehe ich werde aber auf jeden fall
früh schlafen weil ich muss morgen um
halb neun aufstehen und dann lernen
genau also soviel dazu ich bin auch mal
gespannt ich habe jetzt wirklich mein
handy seit heute morgen ich bin ich
heute morgen um 11 oder so da halb zwölf
ich bin mal gespannt wenn ich das morgen
früh an mache wie viele nachrichten
darauf sind mal sehen was ich heute noch
mit mir anzufangen weiß
außer essen machen eigentlich nicht viel
und dann sehen wir uns vielleicht
ähnliches hört aufgefallen
ich habe mich auch mal anguckt ich sehe
aus wie sollen hiervon von
weihnachtsmann co kg diese elfe mit der
mütze oder guck mal wenn man so von
geradeaus drauf weil ich habe eben die
münze getauscht weil ich unter der
anderen so geschwitzt habe und jetzt
sieht das so aus meiner habe gesehen
absolut ach du scheiße leute ist einfach
noch so waren draußen voll krass also
der locker noch 18 19 grad oder so und
das um für den 18
ich hoffe ihr könnt mich gerade ein
bisschen sehen und zwar was ich mal
sagen wollte wenn man mal so überlegt
garantiert bin ich ja nicht der einzige
der oft am handy ist oder so ich meine
ist mein beruf ich bin darauf angewiesen
viel in sozialen netzwerken unterwegs zu
sein sage ich mal aber es echt zu krass
wenn man mal überlegt wie viel zeit man
da rein investiert ich mein wenn man ein
handy hat ihr könnt ja mal die zeit
stoppen ich hätte ihr seid jeden tag
mindestens
drei stunden an dem handys korb durch
instagram oder sonstwas und das sind der
drei stunden die man jetzt nicht
irgendwie mit freunden verbringt oder
eventuell sogar mit freunden während man
nur im handy gilt also sonntag ohne
social media wer allein auch schon ein
cooles experiment gewesen oder so weil
man halt so gewohnt ist immer zum handy
zu greifen deswegen probiert das gerne
aus legt mir einen tag euer handy zu
seinen laptop zur seite und spielt
gitarre so leicht durch noch schnell
sonst endlich das sind die besten
sandwich baguette der welt liegt mir
dein handy weg und sein wird das mache
ich nur wenn du jetzt erstmal die
nächste stunde dein handy beiseite lebst
ja dann nicht
[Musik]
leute ich hatte so eine idee und zwar
wollte ich einen neuen youtube gemacht
und ich habe da so ein designer
beauftragt der wird für mich machen und
er hat es eben nicht ganz verstanden
deswegen wollte ich den das mal malen um
ihnen das morgen zu schicken die idee
ist nämlich ganz einfach ich möchte
praktisch auf dem youtube logo drauf
setzen in noch größer ja und ich hatte
so viel langeweile dass ich mir gedacht
habe alex kommt das zeichen das heute
mal wieder
ich habe wirklich glaube ich seitdem ich
nicht mehr in die schule gehen und
keinen kunstunterricht mehr habe habe
ich nicht mehr gezeichnet also schon ein
weilchen her leute ich bin so dumm
das ding ist da ich ja mein handy weg
gelegt habe und das werde ich nicht
benutzen möchte ich habe einfach keinen
weg ist ist wirklich gerade erst ein
gefallen sodass ich geh jetzt schlafen
und weiß nicht ob ich rechtzeitig wach
werde weil das ding ist ich habe auch
keinen kleinen bäcker oder so das hatte
man ja früher neben dem bett welcher
mensch hat das noch nicht stellen wir
immer mit meinem handy hinweg ich gehe
jetzt einfach schlafen ich hoffe ich
werde sie um halb neun bach oder 9 uhr
keine ahnung das gut ist hier strahlt
immer die sonne rein so wenn die auf g
zum film nach ach ja so zwischen 8 und 9
uhr kleid richtig durch die jalousien
deswegen ist das meine hoffnung und wir
sehen uns morgen früh ich wünsche euch
eine angenehme nachbarn morgen so leute
guten morgen wir haben jetzt noch neun
ich bin zwar ein bisschen zu spät aber
noch relativ früh
ja ich bin vor 20 minuten um cloud
gestanden hat schon gesucht das die
spots einmal hier 147 nachrichten denn
der gruppe euro verpasster sprachanruf
von mama haben nicht so viele leute mir
geschrieben na ja also ich habe ungefähr
vor 22 stunden damit angefangen oder so
ich muss jetzt aber uni fahren auf jeden
fall mit dem auto deswegen würde ich
sagen ich hoffe das video durchgefallen
das ist auf jeden fall die daumen nach
oben da für noch mehr so was irgendwie
in die richtung wo ich immer noch
richtig müde schreibt gerne in die
kommentare was ich noch so 24 stunden
mal testen könnte exception 17 ab wir
sehen uns morgen wieder am morgen gibt
es ein neues video ich wünsche euch eine
schöne woche
ich glaube jetzt ist die wahl wieder
schule führenden vorbei sein und brauche
ich bin zu müde ich will eigentlich
arbeiten schlafen